we're going to turn now to North Korea
where there are new pictures overnight
of the secretive regime of Kim Jong-un
who appears to be trying to send a
message with a new public display of
military hardware a massive parade last
night showed off the North's newest
nuclear hardware and for the second time
this week this is interesting Kim also
put his daughter and possible air on
display here's Elizabeth Palmer
dictator and family man brought his
daughter and wife to the military parade
which featured more intercontinental
ballistic missiles than ever before
designed to reach U.S targets
in 2022 he ordered more than 90 missile
launches a record and watched several
personally while in South Korea just
across the border U.S space force with
powerful satellites and radar was
watching too
Lieutenant Colonel Josh McCullen is the
commander we're using overhead satellite
systems to continuously monitor for an
actual launch while Kim Jong-un has
often attacked the U.S with words he's
only tested his weapons but that in
itself is plenty dangerous as it can
explode in Flight last October warning
sirens sounded over Northern Japan when
a North Korean missile streaked overhead
an overflight of Japan for example
always poses a huge risk especially
whenever you're developing a new system
as North Korea is often doing debris is
a real danger debris is a real danger
for sure
real enough that Japanese school
children were put through a Duck and
Cover exercise earlier this year and
then there's space debris a re-entering
satellite looks very similar to a
re-entering missile if the North Koreans
saw something like this and thought it
was an incoming U.S missile they might
retaliate with lethal consequences so
the U.S government puts out warnings and
hopes North Korea is paying attention
meanwhile last night's parade is a not
so subtle hint of what's in store for
2023. I think the pace is going to
maintain or potentially increase pace of
missile launches from North Korea I just
think it's going to be a much busier
year but
it's 100 why we're here the U.S and its
allies will be scaling up their military
exercises too in a region already so
tense that the price of a mistake on
this calculation could be War
CBS mornings I'm Elizabeth Palmer in
Seoul